une première livraison s'inscrit matiz
heures pour le ch et celle des de
sainte-dorothée à laval en 24 heures
pierre en tient un ancien conseiller
municipal de laval a recueilli plus de
60 climatiseurs qu'il offre gratuitement
aux résidences pour aînés de la région
c'est une des simples quand vous y
pensez c'est quand même assez simple on
fait appel aux simples citoyens
ça va vite parfois les fonctionnaires
les plus du sien mais ont poussé plus
lents et les dons continuent d'arriver
je vais attendre la télévision que vous
remercier d'être climatique huit mois
les attendent à la porte
c'est la fondation de la cité de la
santé de laval qui coordonne la
distribution des équipements
on voulait agir le plus vite possible
alors ça a été coordonné tout s'assurer
qu'on avait les bons contacts dans les
établissements pour pas non plus fournir
quelque chose qui serait pas utile dans
les laurentides
audrey martineau a aussi décidé d'agir
moi j'invite à saint gérand que je
travaille à tremblay a fait que j'ai
beaucoup d'autres affaires j'ai beaucoup
de temps pour réfléchir aussi j'ai
appelé alex ans puis on a décidé de ce
qui fait le ch est élevé à tremblant qui
à la belle en fait on s'est engagé à
acheter
tous ceux qui en ont pas dans ces 2 ch
et celle d'el le alexandre en question
c'est le patron d'audrey martineau il
dirige la plomberie st je vais à mont
tremblant
bonjour monsieur il a accepté de
financer l'achat de tous les
ventilateurs
nous allons interpeller les commander
pour les acheminer directement aux 6h et
seuls 2 des citoyens qui agissent parce
que pour eux il est inconcevable de
laisser des aînés subir une telle
chaleur en restant les bras croisés
vincent maisonneuve radio-canada laval